okay let's hear from a few more people
via the david pakman show discord please
uh sign up i mean it's completely free
i'm selling you nothing
at davidpakman.com discord let's talk to
uh oh i don't know how about how about
megan from california megan or megan the
californian is that
better said megan hi can you hear me
i can hear you fine hi um this is crazy
i
this is my first time calling in i
listen to you every day so thank you
hi um so i yeah i'm from california as
you said
um but i live in england oh wow
and yeah yeah quite the distance um
i don't know if you heard about it but
did you hear about the anti-protest bill
that was
passed here um or at least no i did
i did but i introduced rather i don't
remember yeah not past
introduced i don't remember this exactly
what's in it but i remember it raising a
number of red flags
yes um definitely a red flag razor um
i just was wondering like with the
introduction of the anti-protest bill
in florida and that you know eventual
signing and
now this one in the uk which is
obviously
you know basically a cousin of the us
uh so to speak like is there a growing
like i guess anti-protest movement that
is
actually moving in a way that we should
be genuinely concerned about because i
feel like it is
um i think so i think so what we could
do on that
well i think the problem with a lot of
these bills
is that and and to some degree there's
there may be no
avoiding this a lot of these bills are
designed the florida one i'm most
familiar with
they're designed in a way where it's
basically just
the discretion of whoever the hell
either wants to support or repress
a particular protest movement because
they i think with the florida one there
was something about
once there is once there's more than
three p it's like some really low number
it's like once there's more than three
people
if they are doing harm to property or
putting property at risk of harm then it
can be completely shut down and people
get arrested
and of course the risk of harm to
property
is so subjective uh that
it's just opening the door to saying
well
we don't like the reason that this
protest is happening so then we're going
to apply the law to it
but then we won't apply it to this other
thing so i think it's extraordinarily
dangerous
is obviously like i mean not obviously
but
it seems like the only answer to this is
more protest
um right but before we have to protest
before they pass the laws yeah
no it's i mean listen i think i think
there's something else though i i do
think that this is one of those issues
where
you a lot of these decisions are being
made at the state level
the really all be made at the state
level or even lower sometimes it's
individual municipalities
it's way easier for people to come
together and lobby their local or state
officials than it is
like u.s senators and u.s congressmen so
i think that this is a much bigger
opportunity
for people to really get involved and
work directly with your lawmakers
to change or prevent these types of
bills in a way that is not
as as feasible at the national level
right so it's more of a matter of
contacting your local lawmaker
yes that combined with pros yeah right
okay
so don't don't stop protesting keep
protesting
yes and call your local lawmakers
exactly exactly and vote people out
vote people out if they support this
stuff yes obviously of course
yeah well perfect phone call thank you
david
where in the uk are you did you say
london
no i'm in manchester manchester oh okay
i've never been there i've been to
i've been to london i've been to oxford
i've been to a few other places but
never
manchester is a sizeable city am i right
yes um i would say it's like diet london
um you know if you want to have
a little bit of a smaller um city
and you know uh the locals are great
come come on to manchester the
architecture is beautiful
and are things are things opening now
with the numbers looking so good in the
uk
well yes and no it's a it's a mixed sort
of thing like the
essential businesses and non-essential
businesses i think are
open now so but
uh you can't go inside of restaurants
i believe i haven't really been out too
much um you can go
and sit in like a beer garden which
obviously brits are
thrilled about beautiful and um yeah
it's
it's good but at the same time i'm
honestly kind of concerned about
the well i'm always concerned about this
government here
um right with johnson in charge so i
i am nervous about the release of
the you know astrazeneca vaccine
and stuff throughout the country just
because i don't i don't really trust
them
but maybe that's just more personal
are you wearing a mask outdoors oh of
course i wear a mask
all the time indoors outdoors everywhere
even by yourself at home
everywhere just all the time uh you know
personally when i'm alone sometimes i
like to be a little risky take it off
yeah you know all right well listen stay
uh
stay safe okay thank you all right very
good
appreciate the call thank you um a lot
happening there that's for sure
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with
10 devices logged in at the same time
you can try it for a week for just 99
cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman